a new CNN Oh RC poll indicates that for
the first time ever he's scoring low
basically across the board on all the
polls forty percent of americans now
believe the president obama can manage
the federal government effectively which
is down twelve percent from june fifty
three percent of americans believe that
Obama is not honest and trustworthy so
that's huge right there fifty-three
percent don't view him as strong and
decisive leader fifty-six percent say
he's not a person they admire that also
seems incredibly high fifty-six percent
say he does not agree with them on
important issues fifty-six percent say
he does not inspire confidence there's
something about the 56 number here I
think but then there's a couple things
that are ok and this six in 10 say he
has a vision for the country's future
and seven in 10 say he's likeable so I
know there's a lot of numbers there but
basically this is looking kind of bad is
this just sort of second term lame duck
like you've hung around for a while and
now people turn on but I have to say
that um that tends to be the case date
but we also know people like Clinton
Reagan will ended up being actually a
little more popular in their second
tournament some polling this is the
thing the president has been too
concerned with trying to be right
particularly we will just take the issue
the one everyone's talking about
Obamacare keep like your plan keep your
plan here's an opportunity to say am I
going to try to stay being right or am I
going to be trustworthy and truthful I
think it would have been better played
to say I was wrong on this I am wrong on
this I apologize for this this that
would be weird to make sure that this is
what it is that would preserve
credibility what he did was he
sacrificed credibility and
trustworthiness to try to be right and
that was wrong I don't think that
there's anyone in the White House it's
really giving him honest assessments I
mean let's face it the excuse coming
from the president is usually I didn't
know or some other lame excuse and I
don't what do you mean you don't know
you fire that advisor who was supposed
to tell you right because if they're
holding something back from you either
they have a huge ego or you instructed
them to keep things from you either way
that's a bad process I think a lot of
this is second term problems typical of
what every president goes
I think Obamacare right now is highly uh
toxic it's not going to get fixed I
think politicians are going to be
running from this so a lot of these
numbers are reflective of that I still
think he can come back if he if he does
some of the moments of I wish I would
have done better or been more honest you
think the the apology that he did give
Ricky cuz he basically said sorry about
Obamacare but you think it was too late
and he and he did sort of skirt it now
yeah it was like a can you know that
annoying apology you get for my friend
right I'm sorry that you are offended by
what i said that's BS right right just
own it and I think people are more
forgiving of that than they are for
feeling like you know you're still
skirting the issue and i agree with you
i think his advisors our echo chambers
they're just get really feeding back to
him what they think he wants to hear and
we don't have time for that as anybody
that supports the president generally
speaking and I do it's frustrating I'll
also sink this this is just my thing
just between us is between us guys um
the president we all know comes from a
legal background right and one of the
things we do is try well okay my point
no no to my point to my point right
professor background exactly see I'm a
trial lawyer and one of the things we do
is when our back is against the wall we
come out fighting harder I hate the
posture and and the presentation of this
president in most recent press
conference slouched down you look
defeated stand up big bold in your
assertions of where you have gone wrong
and how you're going to write this
course that is something that I would
like to see from him and you're right
after like we're I know he's the same
let's go have a group meeting at
starbucks and we'll talk this out yeah I
mean that's what you do in a classroom
setting you have more group meetings and
you you talk where's the advocacy this
is a time frame to be an advocate for
the American people in a strong way even
though you've screwed up in some areas
and I think even he knows that in his
kind of acknowledged it you got to
acknowledge those screw-ups strongly I'm
sorry that you trusted me it was really
as apology right so he's part of this
though that
it's very obvious that he likes to be
like you know a lot of people say they
like Bill Clinton like to be in the room
negotiating the deal and that it seems
clear the President Obama he is that he
has this big picture thing but he
doesn't really want to sit down with
everybody and negotiate all the deals so
then it goes to what you're saying
before about how we don't really know
how much he actually knows about what's
happening I think there are other things
that Clinton liked not just being in the
room that's the my first point but I i
I'm not like I couldn't get out of that
without dr. Clinton okay I'm not
surprised that any politician wants to
be liked I think there's a lot of
politicians on the right that loved to
be liked and are crippled by decisions
because of that but there's no question
that this president to me is sheltered
he's got bad advisers who don't give him
the real information and he's really
inexperienced he was a try he was a
professor not someone who ever made
decisions and let's face it as a
community organizer he was a really
lousy one he never finished the job he
was on to the next one promoted before
he ever really finished the job need the
same thing in the Senate so I don't
think he's ever been through something
to see it true I have agree with that
because again I do think he's a
personally believe he's a great
visionary and we even see numbers they
still support that people believe he has
a vision his follow through
implementation and ability to enforce
logistics is a place where he is
faltered and this is a place where if
you know that's in here's my thing my
mom always raised me when you know your
weaknesses and this is place why halfway
won a credit george w bush when you know
what you would listen just kavya here
but when you know what you don't do well
that is your opportunity to surround
recruit and enable yourself with people
that do it exceptionally well and i
would like to see more of it i think
this is one of the republicans problems
too is is that we have been attacking
his vision which his vision is one of
those things that's like you know
everyone should be a part of do you want
people to have health care everyone yes
right you want world peace yes I mean
diploma give diplomacy a chance yes
we've done that the problem is is that
the devil is in the details with him is
because we have tried diplomacy we we
need health care insurance reform that
health
reform you know there are a lot of these
issues that the Republicans have been
terrible at because we've attacked the
vision we need to attack his in
competence well I agree and that's the
thing with Obamacare that's a
frustration for it you know the left we
love the vision to obviously but you've
got all the effort and passion we saw
from the president when he campaigned on
selling this concept to the American
people and to his constituents now we
want to see that same passion I want to
see in the details and the logistics
like how do you get this thing passed a
supreme court challenge but the website
doesn't work like that's crazy and we
keep taking nails are Roberts were right
or or we just keep taking parts of the
law and it's still it's still going
forward which is there's debate where
that's even constitutional but is
another something working to his
advantage here that there's still no
Republicans that any anybody likes I
mean you got chris Christie sort of so
there's just like our bounce back even
though we're still years away from the
election there's just like a general
feeling of like well what have you
learned it they're not going to do any
better you have a bunch of Republicans
that I like what give me a give me three
give you three did you think we could be
electable generally well first of all
scott walker has already demonstrated
that he's won twice in a democratic
state the guy is a great guy a nice guy
who's got a great vision and knows how
to implement buddy what did the changes
that he's going on the the national
stage yes he is a little bit but most
people buy that he's been tried by the
national media already they tried to
bring him down they didn't I think I
think you need to watch him i also like
governor Sandoval in Nevada I think he's
a one to watch and Governor Snyder in
Michigan a great guy who's really been
able to kind of make fundamental changes
I think you got to watch those I'm all
for governor i think i would i would
always say we should never elect another
senator ever again I know ray of all for
you you know I he's not my choice I
don't like his foreign policy vision I'm
a little concerned about that I I think
there are other governors that are
better I'm a place to Rand Paul's
opposition to the Civil Rights Act
that's just why I stand on it I'd like
to put that out there no I do agree i
like seeing a present who has had
executive leadership experience which is
more or less what we see to something
with
yes yes exactly where you're actually in
charge of something for real so I do
think that in implementing and seeing it
through and chiefly responsible for its
implementation which is why I like a
governor going to the president just
presidency as well but I do i do agree i
feel like this is an opportunity for the
GOP to maximize and we'll have to wait
and see if they do that you know got to
come up with a better alternative